lisa's in pittsburgh
hi lisa welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thank you
sure what's up well i own a business
with my ex
and he lives in a house with his brother
and i live in the house that we built
um there's two mortgages
you said where everybody lives who owns
what
my ex and i own the house that i live in
and the house that my brother or
my ex lives with his brother his brother
owned
okay and the point he wants to pay off
his brother he wants to buy his brother
out
and then work on paying the house off
that i live in
that we own together
i wanted to ask what do you think we
should start working on paying off first
this is weird is so weird
i mean you're talking like you're
married yeah that's what i was about to
say i'm confused i hear we
but there is no we he wants to pay off
the house you live in
this do you understand that you
understand this sounds strange
well we run the business together yeah
i do most i do all the bookkeeping
okay um he's a landscaper
who owns the business
well the way i set it up is sole
proprietor so he does
but okay so you work for him
kinda no honey you either own it or you
work for him
well i don't get paid basically
i just pay everything and i manage all
the money
so i've never heard of a owner who
doesn't get paid
well because basically i i
ran the business since we opened it up i
know years ago
um and
so you are you are the situation is
integrated as if you're married
all of these things you're doing are
acting as if you're married and you're
not married which leaves you
very vulnerable and it's making me very
nervous the more you talk
because i'm starting to work i'm
starting to fear for you
so let me tell you exactly how this
could go down he actually owns the
business he could walk in one day and
fire you and hire a bookkeeper
and you would be on the street and you
have made no money
while you work there you've been working
for free did i understand this right
basically but i know he won't do that
yeah
you knew you were gonna stay married
when you got married too
uh well i it wasn't uh
a healthy so yeah which is kind of how
you end up getting screwed on this other
thing too
yeah well um
all right lisa here's the thing
confident i can't i can't i can't i
don't think i don't think i won't be
able to give you really good advice
because it's going to involve you
unraveling a whole bunch of stuff that
you guys have got wrapped together that
you're probably not going to do
so um you're in a very toxic
weird situation and you've left yourself
very vulnerable
and so you guys need to separate your
assets and separate your financial lives
and you need to be paid as an employee
and uh then we need to decide who's
going to get the house
and we're going to sell the house and
you go get you your own house or you buy
him out of the other half of the house
and then you pay off your house
but you guys are integrated in your
lives as
you know if you were his wife and you
worked in the business and didn't
receive a paycheck that would be fairly
normal
yeah fairly normal but you know
you're not you have legally
no rights and your only chance that you
get out of this
is the goodness of his heart and then
you just told me it was a toxic
situation which is why you got divorced
and this is the toxic heart we're
counting on this is danger danger danger
danger danger
yeah so i i'm you're not gonna hear any
of this because you think this is all
perfectly okay and it just sounds
weird as crud over here on this side of
the phone so um
that's what i would do if i were in your
shoes i would separate your lives
since you're not married anymore you
need to start receiving a paycheck
even if it's a percentage of profits
that's fine but somehow you need to be
compensated for your work
and you split these assets off and no by
god you don't need to pay his brother's
off house off
you're not married to him he can pay his
brother's house off
he should have a separate life yeah but
that's cray cray girl
that's just nutty so you're gonna have
to think through this a little different
it it's i and but i have a feeling
you've been running this thing like a
commune for 10 years
and you're used to it yeah so uh but you
are
so vulnerable and then i find you in my
offices for crisis counseling when this
whole thing comes unraveled four years
from now
and you're gonna be broken and busted
and and i'm i don't want that for you
so that's why i'm speaking very plainly
to you
this did sound as weird to use it to me
right it still is weird to me
okay i'm just being honest okay because
i agree i don't know how to give advice
i well i can't you can't you know
there's
too many things here so you need to you
guys need to spend some time in 2021
you can do it gently you don't have to
do it with anger or something but you
need to separate your lives as if you're
divorced
yeah because you are